tutti ragazzi è pervenuto nessun video
sono fa vigenti oggi siamo su un never
ending nightmare
allora prima di ragazzi avevo giocato
alla demo ma tipo un anno e mezzo fa non
mi ricordo neanche più sei proprio non
cinque minuti a farlo ci hanno messo un
pochettino di più però l'hanno fatto
l'importante queste uscite non vedevo
l'ora di giocarlo già una volta quindi
figuriamoci adesso comunque ragazzi
partiamo per che consigliamo di giocare
con le cuffie abbiamo una modalità si
guarda io senza cuffia non riescono
anche uscire di casa quindi va bene a ci
siano comandi ovviamente saltiamo
buongiorno zia tutto bene non è non è il
dentifricio che uso io ricordavo che
iniziasse così cazzo pesante sta cosa
l'aver siamo partiti ragazzi era un
sogno
non ho capito bene di che si tratta suo
gioco per essere una figata cioè una
roba tipo in bianco e nero tra nel
sangue che si vede in rosso ho fatto il
corso cliccato per entrare alla porta
mosone anch'io però i ragazzi
l'obiettivo visto gioco non ho idea di
quale stia servendo una casa abbandonata
questo l'ho capito spero sia a casa mia
perché sono mi stavo dormendo in una
casa a casa di un altro importante che
in italiano a me non devo stare a
tradurre e già e non scatto del solito
quello è caduto da solo
giuro cioè non l'ho toccato io non è che
paranormal quadri tutto il casino cioè
quella è la bambina che è stata
accoltellata prima ma chi sono
la famiglia addams e più bella ragazzi
provato a guardarli un attimo fissi a nè
inquietantissimo tipo allora prima di
andare a dormire metto st schermate la
nostra accesa tutta la notte vuoi vedere
che cazzo succede
ma chi sono io di precisa ma forse il
bambino che è cresciuto penso che sia
così perché sennò non capisco qual è il
senso
e vabbè andiamo avanti c'era il quadro
di un alcolizzato questo non è caduto
almeno fatemi capire madonna che quadri
inquietanti però ragazzi almeno un po di
vitalità e sta casa che roba arriva il
tuo animale domestico quello lì e non è
proprio bellissimo a vedersi prova be
dai noi animati non so c'è un tizio ma
c'era un cazzo di pizzo nell'armadio ma
come lasciam perdere i tizi nella magia
entravo nella porta perché comunque sta
diventando alquanto strano sto gioco ve
lo dico ci sono presenze strani sporca
ladra cioè schiantato un piccione sulla
finestra perfetto ma io ho sempre detto
che mettiamo un cazzo di semaforo per i
piccioni che almeno non si che poi sono
solo delle idee poi ognuno può fare il
cazzo che vuole però
nemmeno provarci cos'è carne tritata
ragazzi non fate i complimenti
assaggiate cucina fa vita eh lo so dai
adesso prendi 2 cipolle facciamo un po
di di rock cos'è a c'è una mannaia
sporca di sana perché sangue si vede
rosso il resto si cade in bianco e nero
spiegato leggermente inquietanti io
prenderei del parmigiano iniziare
grattugiare ragazzi come volete la pasta
al sugo
sì direi di si preparano dopo la pasta
fatemi vedere prima cosa diavolo ci qua
dietro sono uscito ma davvero ma è anche
diverso dalla demo che ho fatto nero mai
uscito nella dentata piedi nudi scalzo
proprio nella merda potrebbe provarci
cagato un cane per terra ma ok tanto la
merda portafortuna sarà pesto dove sta
andando ragazzi pur essenso di sta roba
sì però zio stai calmo che viene l'ansia
così cos'è un cimitero alla famiglia ai
un cimitero fuori da casa ma che
problemi mentali il ciai farvi capire a
che belle le cose colorate in sto gioco
mi danno non so che di gabrielle cosa
sta succedendo in ha avuto un incubo
terribile ho sognato che riporta che
sciocchezze sto benone poi avevi
promesso di prenderti sempre cura della
tua sorellina
quindi ragazzi non ho capi allora questa
mia sorella allora non è morta mia
sorella fatemi capire qual è il senso ai
miei genitori di sicuro novara ci
scommetto un nuovo lettimi genitori sono
morti quello sicuramente solo che mia
sorella è viva cioè non pensavo fosse
viva è il nesso di sto già perché allora
sono andato di sotto io non sto capendo
perché fai certe cose allora c'è tua
sorella che ti ha detto che è uscita
perché devi andare in cantina qual è il
senso ma mio dio
ok c'era un ascia per terra e mi sono
risvegliato cosa cazzo sta succedendo
lagarde cos'è inception irachena non sto
capendo questo gioco cioè non so se è
difficile che cos'è ci sono dei denti ma
ne dica allora quel dentifricio non è
buono e avevo detto già dall'inizio
avevo detto di chi sono quei denti
soprattutto visto che non sono sporco di
sangue di chi è stato ma l'obiettivo di
questo gioco e trovare mia sorella ma
cosa devo fare
facevano sti tizi prima di fare sta vita
di merda ecco ci son delle marionette
che bello ascoltate ragazzi devo trovare
mia sorella non è che ve la siete
inglobata voi nobel favore ditemi di no
ai ragazzi perché non è che pos che mi
scusi non voleva disturbare la sua
seduta spiritica adesso mi devo dai
[ __ ] pin si preoccupi sto continua
andare andrà avanti ragazzi senza capire
dove stop o mio dio mio no seriamente va
beh ma che schifo
guarda zio tir e galoppo di palloncini
colorati per il compleanno perché mi
piace ai un qualcosa di meno tetro
insaccati clan nell'ombra che mi ha
appena passato davanti alla finestra
non ho capito che cos'è la quella roba
ma poco mi interessa mi devo dalle palle
immediatamente perfetto vado a vedere se
c'è qualcos'altro di qua così a me la
devo trovare una luce gesù che culo ho
avuto un culo incredi non so come ho
fatto ma va bene a volte basta chiederle
cosa sia compaiono davanti perché voglio
una donna
gli occhi si ma che mi ecco no non è
proprio una donna gnocca vabbè ci
abbiamo provato ragazzi my god why he
view forsaken mio dio mio perché non mi
hai perdona ma sono io questo sono io
sono morto a terra ma come se sono qui
come è possibile non so se vi siete
accorti prima è però è molto strano e
buio
[ __ ] vacca perfetto ci sono anche i
tuoni prega quando c'è stato quel
fulmine ho visto una tizia le mie spalle
vi giuro non lo sono sognato mar
andiamo fuori dai [ __ ] porca [ __ ]
via via via via via via via no no no no
non sia da una scorta un po di make up e
ci togliamo tutto il pensiero che hai
porca vacca
no non ti fermare 90 gradi che poi
notiziati in groppa come si deve di
rimuovere il culetto bravo perché se non
finiamo malissimo e finiamo e malissimo
tutti e due poli collaborazione zio cioè
dammi la mano e vabbè ma siete stronzi
allora quest'ombra che passa ogni tanto
che cosa dovrebbe essere taccini alla
fine sono tornato dov'ero e la meglio se
ne stava a dormire [ __ ] tutto ecco
di qua adesso che sosta maledetta
candela posso prendere lascia e sfondare
la porta però mica posso prendere la sea
peron la posare la candela cribbio due
mani con una temi lascia con l'altra tv
a porca di quella [ __ ] vacca corrie
che cosa cazzo appena visto ragazzi non
si stava togliendo le vene sarà
semplicemente il cavetto dell'iphone che
si era dimenticato dentro il braccio
porca lavarci a chi scrive è stata
quanto scena ma va bene ragazzi ho
trovato lascia però mi son dovuto
assorbire in compenso un tizio che si
toglieva le vene con chi è che sta
spegnendo le luci se ti stanchi e titti
akashi ti ammazzo la famiglia ma si
spengono quando posso io a si vede che
scorre joe dibrutto qualcosa del genere
cosa sta succedendo lo stesso rumore di
catene bruttissimo sento delle catene
alla mia sinistra sfonda sta cazzo di
porta per favore ok
ringraziamo gesù io in questa sala terrà
fino alla fine del gioco non si sa mai
che la devo dare in testa qualcuno dove
siamo
c'è una soffitta pure sorella mia
adorata guarda che ci avevo letto comodo
non c'è bisogno di dormire così è ora
che si e scomodi 20 zia e che è successo
ma apre gli occhi come fare lo sapevo è
ma ci avrei scommesso penso anche il
pelo della mia chiappa destra però vabbè
ho giocato talmente tanti horror che
ormai sto cosa succede questa cosa
il lato è cambiata la stanza di social
nar madio qualcuno ha voglia di
spiegarmi perché tanto sa qualcuno nel
mentre che mi sveglio sta sempre più
sfasciando la casa non ho capito chi
susanna ma anche piacere ma c'è una
tizia con un velo che dei fiori alla
scorta zia per disturbo alla quiete
pubblica ti do cortesemente chiedere gli
toglierti il velo perché si
esageratamente brutto o certo guarda per
gli stessi motivi
rimettiti da un velo al giorno toglie il
favi jd torno normale un detto molto
famoso ma dalla prossima volta che vedo
un tizio brutto in qualsiasi videogioco
ci ficco sopra un velo c'è un armadio a
narnia cernia non c'è un cazzo sono
uscito come prima va beh è ciò che hanno
provato ma per chi sosterrà ambo le col
culo per terra e ancora non l'ho capito
vabbè che è sempre meglio un culo gelato
che un gelato nel culo però che palle
c'è una roba ancora ma basta se cantine
mio dio ragazzi se io diventassi ma il
presidente degli stati uniti d'america
prima legge a livello proprio mondiale
vietate le cantine cioè la pena di morte
per i trasgressori ancora ma basta
all'ascolto zia ti devi togliere ma sei
meno brutta dai possiamo accettare fate
capire chi cazzo sono queste col velo
ho come la sensazione netta che sta
cazzo di bambola mi saltare addosso
non so perché ha chiuso gli occhi
ragazzi ha chiuso gli occhi ok ed
ascolta miti passo dall anno mi ha fatto
niente per perocchio ha chiuso gli occhi
quello l'ho visto ma guarda se mi fate
capire dove sto andando senza troppi
giri di minchia ma che bel bambino ma
non fare il birichino a me finto amica
non avevo visto avessi già le ragnatele
nel culo quindi probabilmente finto ma
senti ancora lì al magma basta mi
servono a qualcosa stia armadio centro e
basta fatemi capire allora ragazzi io vi
devo fare un discorso molto serio
non prendete mai gli steroidi ok mai
nella vita perché succede questo
porca [ __ ] non mi appresto solo
nell'armadio prof non mi ha visto
ma cosa come ancora fatto non vede
ascolta zio sam ishak eri ancora ti
cercherò la mamma ok vedi tutto steroidi
niente cervello ragazzo è importante
questo contento lui ragazzi aspetto che
passi dalle travolta e poi l'ora giro di
nuovo che va donna la budria che lì si
muove mentre sballottolato per uscire
che supera uscire bye bye corri corri
gente corre e pro vasto da nella sua
tappa rami il culo mentre non ci sono
prega per me ma può venire anche qua io
tanto scende in cantina guarda lui è
stupido come la morte ma è abbastanza
intelligente da capire che in cantina
non ci deve scendere quindi non ti
preoccupare che non ti segue dove stiamo
andando
attivare i tassi permanenti non attivati
tua sorella grazie cosa cazzo già perché
si è chiuso il gioco così sede che è mio
computer e contro questo videogame
ragazzi faceva paura ed è uscito sei
tranquillo computer ci sono io che ti
difendo da questi bambini brutti non ti
preoccupare ma ho scelto talmente porca
[ __ ] corri corri veloci veloci veloci
veloci veloci cori come mia nonna il
calore vai madonna tutto del deretano
oh cazzo questo sfondo entra entra in
arma anzi no entro di qua e tra i 4 e
sto andando legadue sta cosa sta
succedendo
cioè non ne fossi dai ragazzi conclude
episodio è stato in quanto strano ma
veramente tanto strano fatemi sapere se
volete che lo continui avrei veramente
strana come storia mai secondo me è
mette una tensione addosso che non ha
eguali quasi cosa sei ragazzi seguito vi
è piaciuto lo stato quinto mi piace
anche a fagiani facebook e coni via
tratta nella descrizione sensore ccd da
ragazzi